hey guys I'm Ryan right hey guys I'm
Ryan right we're gonna be watching a
trailer today for a movie called little
boy we're gonna be watching a trailer
today for a movie called a little boy uh
I'm ready price though for real
yeah that's her real name ah you know I
saw the first trailer for this is
actually really good
it's really too soon to make any
diagnosis let's just say your little boy
my story takes place on the home front
it's time to go to bed I was good in the
old Busby hum or so I thought yes
won't work if you - bit of doubt
Oh
origin story Neal
it takes courage to be here father would
be more than proud of you
you sure yeah they'll be great for a
camera if you cried right I'm pretty
sure those Catholicism they were dealing
with it looked like a priest at the time
from Tom Wilkinson but this is obviously
like one of those must be some type of
those like Christian based there's a lot
of these there's a lot of films coming
out in the past few years it's very
Christian based the production company
like everything they do revolves around
Christianity and sometimes this I think
is one of those I'm assuming yeah
without being so clear about it so crisp
it's like they're not telling the little
boy believe in Jesus and all this will
happen but they are teaching him like
have faith yeah exactly yeah so it's a
story about faith and it's from the
producers of son of God which was about
Jesus coming to assume that it is from
them and it looks really good for like
I've seen trailers for those other ones
they've gotten like decent reviews this
looks like it could be a really good
film and I love that message and I like
how they're going all out like he's
actually moving the [ __ ] mountain
yeah no I thought it was really cool it
reminded me a little bit so a sickly a
big fish yes yes would this cast
assemble that looks like a really good
film like it looks fun and it looks very
moving [ __ ] loose little corny but it
looks [ __ ] negative yeah that was
cool
I liked how they went all out with the
faith stuff at first it kind of seemed
like oh it's like okay the kids didn't
move the [ __ ] bottle lose the
magician it looks like this guy's this
kid's gonna have like trauma there's
something from their dad leaving and
then it has faith and it's like whoa if
they're going all out with the faith
stuff don't usually see that anyway guys
if you're new to the channel you know
what you can do you can subscribe to the
real rejects brandy has a channel she
does independent movie reviews yeah you
want to go do
dazzling time button to subscribe
are you group and you can follow us on
Instagram Twitter and Facebook oh yeah
yeah my as
that are not out there these days I mean
sure Matthew Kingsbury Schultz fuzzy
wuzzy was a bear fuzzy wuzzy had no hair
fuzzy wuzzy has never given me a
shoutout could you cover for him you
guys are awesome my youtube channel is
viga life thank you
here is a picture of my channel is it
Vega life or vegan life ah dead to life
he spelled it wrong it's bad life the 5
things you need to know about guys they
like the life of the vag not all guys
well you know if you disobey your
biology I was gonna do [ __ ] up again
with that Oh taking a religious stance
here this guy logs yeah so he's a little
logger
he's a vlogger he gets in front of the
mean oh man you know one on the camera
talking I've always told people if you
can't figure out what to do with your
life vlog just record yourself talking
about [ __ ] and somehow out of the
millions of people on YouTube thousands
will be drawn to you is [ __ ] weird but
that's how it works